utah jazz seven wins in a row longest
winning streak in the nba
oh my goodness all right and mitchell
he is something else
[Music]
got off to that big start in that first
quarter yep
14 assists between the two you know
leading scorers and
major ball handlers are excellent
mitchell
almost looked like a lob instead it goes
off the window at it he can score in a
variety of ways
more importantly new orleans five made
threes
already here in this first quarter
[Applause]
[Music]
on a drive into the paint kick out three
balls up donovan
rudy big offensive rebound and no looker
no
donovan two-handed i'm not sure where
gary win i guess on the other end
tapped out picked up here's donovan
tackles of paint and one oh the strength
the confidence the determination
mitchell with 13
with a chance for a three-point play
able to draw the contact too
and finish great concentration look at
the spin the english on the ball
it's gonna go out to mike he'll drive
inside
back out donovan all he needs is a
two-point shot drives off the window and
count it
big bucket mitchell glass and the jazz
by one
at four down to three clarkson
gives it away
we've seen donovan get caught in short
shot clock situations and he delivers
seven assists mitchell's still trying to
get on the books folks
whoa watch mitchell folks
gymnastic acrobatics wheeling and
dealing on this one
utah jazz seven wins in a row longest
winning streak in the nba
and mitchell he is something else
it's just off the movement that's a
tough cover for steph will you talk
about
what's going to get down to the next
level
he's doing a lot more of that right
there
rudy's out of his chair just trying to
stay loose now he sits back down
i don't know maybe that's like hooking
up a battery t
and recharging things nick patoon
getting in the latest on the mitchell
poster
what up it's your boy adam lefkow do you
like that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleacher report